daymo beerus theorem tells us is that if
we want to raise a complex number to a
power we want to do is put the complex
number into the trigonometric form and
then to raise it to the nth power what
you're going to do is you're going to
raise the R value to the nth power but
you're gonna multiply the angle by the
nth power okay so this is how you take
it from a you know just the
trigonometric form raised to a power you
just raise the R value to that power and
you multiply the angle by the power
let's look at an example say we want to
find out okay if Z equals two plus two
is these are complex number we want to
find Z to the fifth power now if we
wanted to do this a long way we could
take two plus 2i times two plus 2 I 2
plus 2 I 2 plus 2 I 2 plus 2 I we could
multiply it five times this would take a
long time because you're you have a
binomial times a binomial you'd have to
foil that out then you'd have to do the
distributive property simplify
distribute and so on it would take a
long time so what we're going to do is
we're used a mole verus thing we're
going to convert this to the
trigonometric form I like to draw a
diagram just to see what I'm working
with here 2 plus 2i means you're going
right to and up to there's your point in
the complex plane and there's the R
value right there and there's the angle
right there so what we're going to do it
we're going to do R equals the square
root of a-squared plus b-squared okay
which equals 4 plus 4 which is square
root of 8 which is 2 root 2 so that's
our value theta equals the tangent
inverse of B over a which is 2 over 2
this is one tangent equals 1 at 45 or PI
over 4 and you can see this is PI over 4
so if we write this in trigonometric
form what we have is 2 root 2 cosine PI
over 4 plus I sine PI over 4 okay so
there's our complex number the same
number here just in a different form
trigonometric form now what we're going
to do is we're going to raise both sides
to the 5th power we're going to use de
Meaux varus theorem we're going to raise
the r-value to the 5th power so that's 2
root 2 to the 5th and we're going to
multiply the angle by 5 so we're not
raising it to the 5th power just
multiplying it by 5 so that's 5 PI over
4 plus I sine 5pi over 4 2 root 2 to the
5th 2 to the 5th is 32 square root of 2
to the 5th is actually going to be 2
times 2 is going to be 4 times 2 is 8
times 2 is 16 times 2 is 32 square root
of 32 is 4 root 2 so that's times 4 root
2 so we get 128 square root of 2 okay
and then cosine of 5 PI over 4 is
actually going to give us negative root
2 over 2 and sine of 5 PI over 4 is
negative root 2 over 2 I so if we
distribute we get 128 divided by 2 is 64
square root of 2 times square root of 2
is 128 times the negative that's a
negative 128 same thing here so that's
going to be negative 128 I so this is a
lot faster way than having to foil out
this binomial 2 plus 2i 5 times what you
can do is just translate it into the
trigonometric form and use damo varus
theorem by taking the R value to
whatever power you're working with and
then multiplying that powers value times
the angle and then if you want you can
then distribute okay this R value back
in to change it back into the standard
form of a complex number the a plus bi
form so this has been how to work with
Damo verus theorem i'll see you in the
next video